[Applause]
all right before we say goodbye we have
time for One More Story this is what I'm
liking the pandemic was hard on everyone
especially teenage boys that's according
to Chicago based clinical psychologist
Dr John Duffy but he also says there's
hope which he writes about in his new
book rescuing our sons eight solutions
to our crisis of disaffected teen boys
Dr Duffy is dialed in right now he
watches on NBC Chicago what's up Dr
Duffy hi Kelly how are you I'm so good
thank you for thank you for joining us
so what changes have you noticed okay so
since the pandemic teenage boys are
telling me they are sad they're really
quite lonely and they're disconnected
from themselves and from their emotions
they don't really understand their
emotions very well because we haven't
taught them to do that they don't
understand the emotions of the people
around them we know they're disconnected
from us as parents because they're up in
that room with the door closed or down
in the basement playing video games
right um and they're also disconnected
from their peers because they're they
they really don't have the great
language to speak to them they talk via
Snapchat or video games with them so the
rich discussions we want them to have
they don't really have and they don't
really feel worthy of those good
relationships all this funnels into a
sense of hopelessness that has me
concerned about our teenage boys right
now yeah and what will happen as they
grow older if they don't have those
skills so what do you recommend for
parents yeah so what parents tend to do
is focus on um those things like the
behaviors that our boys engage in that
don't work for them right if I could
only get them to do uh X and Y through a
series of punishments and consequences
then everything would be fine I want
parents to abandon that for now and
focus on your relationship with them and
the emotional bank account that you have
in that relationship and light up for
them when you see them this is super
important because so many boys tell me
nobody ever through the course of a day
month year lights up for them at all so
use that emotional bank account watch
what he's watching listen to what he's
listening to you can provide a
Counterpoint some of the negative
vitriolic stuff he's hearing on podcasts
on video games through YouTube videos it
is a win-win win for parenting Kelly um
who wouldn't want to be a part of that
yeah be involved is really is really
what it sounds like well rescuing our
sons eight solutions to our crisis of
disaffected teen boys is out now and
everyone is going home with a
copy thank you so much Dr zy I'm liking
your post right now right thank you sh
and that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers have precise
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
appreciate the work that you're doing we
mentioned the National Alliance on
Mental Illness in the last segment so on
your behalf pilot will be writing them a
check for $1,000
fantastic thank you thank you so much Dr
Duffy and thank you to all our guests
this hour Dan Levy Cora theena buado who
I known
[Music]
[Applause]
as thank you guys y'all have a great
night guys I'm going
home